this is a paid for promotion by
lootcrate who opposed in Hugo Hattori
Hanzo place his most valuable items in a
sacred ancient box and scented a total
future it alright how's it going bros my
name is pierre today I've waited 2,000
years to make this episode we're going
to unbox a box from Japan we got a lot
of sexual stuff in here close your door
put on headphones lock your door
barricade your door because it's about
to get sexual this is the dream of men
it looks even more like boobs now this
is how you get away with censorship on
YouTube Mitch alright the dream of man
it took me a while to get this a certain
girlfriend can't know about the cider oh
my god are you guys ready to see the
drain moment away
[Applause]
[Music]
dream oh man everyone hey look guys I'm
Miley Cyrus alright ok it's a very
classy way to send some nuts to your
guests all right next item Oh Hatari
that's hilarious
so now I'll be able to hear super well
let's try it out
next item if you wanted to stick
something in your friends face
what would you stick you don't have any
friends no surprises here but if you
wanted to stick something in random
people's faces poop come here come here
yeah you like that put your face on the
screen yeah yeah you like that smelly
smell like hey Edgar
ha ha ha ha ha ha
stupid stupid dumb what's that cameraman
huh you want some [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] gay so this is last month's
theme May and the famous power I wonder
if it will be as powerful as I am and
next month's theme is dystopian comes
out of the 19th so make sure you're
ordering by then
make sure you check out Luke ryokan
slash pivots link is in the description
it supports the show and we can open it
together like a family and if you use
the code fuse you get 10% up which is a
good offer here we go
I immediately see a cooking hand this is
from Simpsons that's the Infinity
Gauntlet this has been listening in on
that which is also used in in classic
American TV show of the same size that's
pretty cool I needed one of these so
that's perfect oh this is perfect right
here this is a dragon ball from famous
anime Tokyo ghoul
hey yo you want this ball yeah that's
right he loves it
we got a t-shirt a Warcraft t-shirt this
is cool see how much you get see I'm
gonna battle you finally we have an
action figure I believe this is Wonder
Woman it's cute I like it you know what
I'm gonna keep this right here who would
win back members hug the help what do
you think we also get a pin
yeah yep you're bleeding yeah yeah check
out Luther calm that's right you guessed
it back - here can we get the helium
tank please all right
why does it feel like one of those [ __ ]
doll you know what I mean I want to have
a Santa sink toilet with your dick Oh
[ __ ] yeah look at me like that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] we gonna tell your parents
oh yeah yeah pump that [ __ ] Batman look
like someone that's been jerking off a
bit too much am i right Batman found it
oh yeah so I need a plumber for my
instinct is starting to leak so for the
next I am
[Music]
I wonder why we're getting kicked out by
Batman did you ever fix that all right
next item please I final item the moment
we all been waiting for
to watch peopIe get a butt massage is it
nice
is it discomforting okay so this is how
it looks like it's very pretty
would you put this on your butt we have
to put it on my Play who wants to put it
on my back no this is real sticky it's
gonna go in my house my concern is that
if it's not comforting I really can't
get it off because it's glued to my ass
you know when I started PewDiePie five
years ago I did not see myself putting
on butt massage for millions of people
first thing you guys see my hands come
on okay this is my ass it's on Michael
can you help me Michael I just day Oh
Michael what you doing only Martha can
touch my ass you know that
thank you little bit more give it to me
a little bit more okay whoo oh I like it
and it's like a butt massage it is gets
a little too intense the best thing
about this is that I can wear it
well step look well it work okay can we
up the but a little bit is that Elmore
take the setting how it takes it back
oh it's like tiny hands are biting my
ass
[Music]
don't look at me
oh no more vana
[Music]
ah
get off
[Music]
that's sexual harassment
I'll have you know we got that on camera
I told you to lock the door all right
remember just hangers grab a comm slash
pewds and if you compute they're our
sponsor they're literally the only one I
really appreciate that you guys check
them out to support the show thank you
so much it helps to keep going and we
can keep finding which items and [ __ ]
like that
Luthor complex boots 10% off brokest oh
but it's soft
[Music]
hey you want oh my god it smells like
ass no like ah